hello everyone and welcome back to the
gold money asian rapid knockouts we are
still in the quarterfinals and we are uh
added the game uh
a lot of you have been requesting is the
second game of the match
versus levon and the first uh game they
played ended in the draw this one
however uh perhaps did not we'll see
we'll see what happens in the game
uh but it features uh well a lot of
really awesome moves uh probably why you
guys suggested it so without further ado
let's check it out
and see why so many of you suggested it
and if you're wondering what happened to
the fourth game between magnus and
wesley well
uh the game uh ended in a draw
and magnus wins the first match i i said
it very slowly so if some of you didn't
want to know the result you could have
just skipped
that's how that's how we do things here
uh but now getting to this game
uh let's check out what happened so uh
audio opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 we have c4
uh e6 knight to f3 and d5 now so just a
normal queen's gambit declined
uh knight to c3 and bishop to be for
going for the
ragosan defense of the queen's gambit
declined e3 and we have castles by levon
bishop to d2
and now b6 preparing toffee and get to
the light square
bishop we have bishop to d3 uh but not
quite yet
after b6 11 first captured once we have
e captures and
bishop to d3 and now levon has a couple
of ways he can play this he can just
castle he can even ignore castling uh
sorry not the one aryun i can
just ignore castling he can maybe play
h4 h5 just you know
keep attacking uh but all depends on
what level one plays so here bishop to
b7 by levon
and the castles by aryon uh we have
bishop back to e7 the bishop no
is no longer needed on the on the queen
side and now knight
to e5 a very nice square and outpost for
this knight
we have c5 challenging the central pawn
with the c
pawn push and now the position has been
reached before uh but
uh the move that um uh is played in the
game uh
has not been reached so here f4 f4 is a
normal queen to f3 is a known move rook
the c1 is a known
move even bishop to e1 is a known move
for to save defeated
ciaparino with this bishop to e1
maneuver but in the game we have knight
to eq and knight to e2 baroon is a new
move so already as a movie 11 we have a
completely new game
and you can see how uh how an aggressive
move this is because now
you want to go after this knight you
want to eliminate it so the queen can
enter the game
basically you want to get this knight to
g3 then to h5 challenge this knight and
then the queen will be able to
take these squares that the black knight
is currently covering
so here uh we have knight to the c6
level one continues developing with
knight characters b captures and now d
captures and the b
captures and now with this set of trades
uh aryun gets this bishop the c3 moving
and now
uh his bishop pair from hell is fully
operational
uh we have queen to b6 levon develops
the queen connects the rooks
uh and now uh again uh what do you do
here it's not a very
active move with the queen but uh he he
has to develop somehow
knight to g6 arduino just continues with
his plan and now
g6 levon cannot allow this knight to h5
move he has to play this
but now he has weakened the f6 square
and white will use this to his advantage
and
uh here comes a move that i really
really like it is
maybe not my favorite move the game but
it is uh oh
maybe it's my favorite movie of the game
here aryan played b4
and it's not just because it's the b4
movie it has nothing to do with that
it's just because it completely uh uh
ruins black's pawn structure
and it wins the d4 square for white's
dark square bishop and
then you will you will not be able to
challenge this dark square bishop for
for the rest of the game
so here at c captures on b4 uh it's a
pawn sacrifice but you know now bishop
to d4 and now this bishop is a monster
and you will never be able to
challenge it by uh either pushing c4 or
d4 here so here
queen back to d8 and now rook to c1
uh developing the piece with tempo so
this bishop has to move
bishop to b7 and now comes queen to f3
uh which tempo as the knight is now
being pressured okay the queen defends
it so not really with tempo
but you are putting a lot of pressure on
this knight here so queen to d6
uh again developing the queen and again
connecting rooks
and now white uh put all his pieces
perfectly and now it's time to push
the h pawn so h4 you want to play h5 uh
must open the position and you know try
to utilize this bishop pair to its
fullest
we have rook f the c8 and now h5 of
course
we have a5 levon says all right you're
definitely not checkmating me on the
king side
i'm just gonna play a5 then maybe a four
b3 i'm going to create a pass pawn on
the queen side
and i'm going to win the game this way
so these are the two objectives that
the the players are going for uh and
here comes uh
the the move i really really enjoy
uh also not maybe not as much as b4 but
you know maybe just as much
uh bishop to f5 and this is just a
beautiful idea
uh point is that the bishop cannot be
captured but you are forcing black to
decide what to do with this rook and
basically you are winning the c
file with this uh because if the bishop
is captured then it's just knight
captures an f5 with a double attack here
and now we've uh we can remove one of
the defenders of the night so we're
going to win our piece back it's not
even a peace sacrifice after the queen
moves just captures with
check queen captures and now we can
capture here and it's of course
completely winning for
for white it's not um and not what black
wants to do
so instead after bishop f51 says all
right my rook is under attack i'm going
to capture this rook we have rook
captures on c1
and now knight to e8 getting this knight
out of harm's way and
shifting it over to g7 to attack the
bishop here on f5
we have queen to g4 now the g pawn is
pinned and
now comes knight to g7 and now we reach
the position
uh that um uh well yeah i want you guys
to solve uh it's a really really cool
position and there is only one move that
wins the game for white
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for aryun
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea
as it was not played in the game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
bishop caltrason g7 such a such a
such a quaint move to find uh but it's a
brilliant one
uh in the game uh first a captures on g6
occurred but
i will show you why capturing on g7
first is stronger
because after bishop captures king
captures and the now bishop captures on
g6
this is now deadly uh because you are
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and
if the bishop is captured by either pawn
then knight f5 check wins the queen as
the g
pawn is again pinned so capturing on g7
is crushing but in the game bishop
captures and g6 came first
and now it's a little bit different now
levon captures here we have bishop
captures on g7 but now levon will not
capture this bishop but we'll rather
play
rook the c8 and now levon's plan is that
he wants to give back some material for
example
he wants rook captures on c8 with check
bishop capture screen captures
and now king captures and g7 and we have
this uh
end game with a completely equal
material this is what levon is going for
however after work the c1 aryon decided
nope
i'm playing rook to d1 first and i'm
keeping all of my threats on the board
king captures is still impossible
uh so what do you play here uh here
levon has to find rook to c4 this is the
crucial move that uh
allows him to stay in the game but he uh
postponed it for one move he first
played rook the c2
but now uh he he allows this bishop to
retreat
very safely with rook bishop to a1
and now uh you can easily open up the
position here with white so now
he did play rook to c4 but now it's a
it's a move late we have queen to e2
and now the problem is there's also uh
there are also very nasty threats of
maybe even queen captures any uh here if
the bishop ever moves from the defense
of the queen then we can pick up the
queen
so queen to c6 now levon wants to push
this pawn and open up this diagonal
and now comes another very nice move
bishop to d4 just blockading the
uh the the d5 pawn and not allowing it
to be pushed forward
we have bishop to f6 trying to trying to
get rid of this bishop
but now h captures on g6 we have h
captures in g6
and now king the h2 another beautiful
move
simply preventing rook to c1 because
here as long as the king is on
on the back rank you can do such ideas
because
uh the the capture will come with check
but here it's impossible because if you
trade then the bishop is unguarded
there is no check here so instead after
king to h2 we have bishop captures on d4
now comes e captures on d4 again keeping
this pawn on d5 completely
making this light square bishop useless
that one has on b7
so here rook to c2 now attacking the
queen and now queen to f3
so okay the position come calmed itself
a little bit
and levon uh even uh gained uh quite a
nice position
but it's very very difficult to play
queen to e6
and now comes queen to f4 so what do you
play here we have king to g7 but now
rook to d3 now the rook will also join
the attack and then you really have to
be careful
so queen to f6 here levon offers a queen
trade but
queen to g for now so uh the thread is
of course knight to h5 check which would
win the black queen the g pawn is again
pinned
uh and here you have to go back queen
the sixth uh remain
uh you know uh for the position to to
not be ruined the knight is now pinned
it cannot move
uh and the white doesn't have any any
active moves white can slowly continue
mounting the pressure but
you know then black will slowly bring
the bishop into the game via bishop to
c8 and so on
however here levon played queen captures
on f2 and it does make sense he went
upon your threatening checkmate
but now it's completely lost for levon
here audrey and played knights the h5
with
check and now it doesn't matter what you
play if you go to the f file then rook
f3 just wins the black queen
and if you go to the h file which
happened in the game
then knights to f4 defending against
checkmate now with the
knight and the queen also threatening
checkmate here as the queen and the
knight attacked the g6 square
so rook the c6 defending uh and now
rook to h3 with czech king g7 now comes
queen
to d7 with check king to f6 and now
rook to f3 and now you really don't have
uh
uh any any moves that that you can play
here uh whatever you play you're just
going to run into a very nasty discovery
and
it with with the best possible defense
it's made in
18 moves uh but levon just played queen
captures on the e4
and here after knight to e2 check it was
in this position on
43 that levon resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh the
queen is under attack and once the king
moves you're just gonna gobble up the
queen and now you're getting checkmated
there's nothing you can do here
so really an incredible uh game by arya
nergaisi uh defeating lavon arunan
uh in in their second game of the match
like that
uh but uh levon was able to bounce back
in the third game
and i believe the fourth game ended in a
draw i will however
check uh before i give you the final
results yeah i live on bounce back in
the third game and then the fourth game
ended in a draw but so
uh the match uh is a tie and will be
decided tomorrow so this
uh i consider uh well a huge
accomplishment for
uh for young uh aryan and uh well it's a
really really incredible achievement
beating levon like that
uh so basically at his own game
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
david kimura nigel holloway happy
birthday gavin leander
uh mother son and happy birthday ccp for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day